[Science Blaster- DHMIS remix] (nice music matpat)
Hello internet! Welcome to Film Theory!
Where too much watching won't make your teeth go grey. It'll make 'em FALL OUT! (OH-NO VIEWERS GET OUT OF HERE
You might not know about this about me, but one of my favourite entertainment genres
is puppet psychological horror that comments on the state of modern children's
programming... I have very specific tastes.
So, it'll come as no surprise that I am thrilled
that Don't Hug Me I'm Scared is coming back
for more
Now if you're not familiar with DHMIS
The show is a six part series that
felt a lot like BlumHouse got a hold of
Sesame Street.(Oh no! they took my childhood!) Or the muppets just got a wee bit too
sick of being so good and wholesome all the time and went
all american psycho.(like the the movie pyscho?) After this series "allegedly concluded"
I did two part theory trying to unravel the messages
of the series while also piecing together the
lore within the show itself. And that's where things ended
two years ago. With DHMIS (relegated) to the
archives YouTube where would live in (infamy)
joining the ranks of Marble Hornets and Salad Fingers as
Twisted web series that would deliver creepy nostalgia for a
generation of youngsters, at least that's
what I thought. Then, out of nowhere the channel
suddenly became active again, dropping a new trailer entitled
"Wakey Wakey" to announce that the show was coming back
"Great! Great news!" (no pun included)
When? It's unclear.
Where can we watch it? Also unclear.
Maybe YouTube? But given it's now got the backing of Conaco the Production
company for Conan O' Bryan's show (never heard that show)it's really
anybody's guess. What's the show gonna be about? Now
that I think I can answer. Sure, the trailer left a lot
people asking themselves,
"I wonder what will happen.." (Me too red guy)
and it IS only 20 seconds of footage
"That's not enough time!" (SHUT IT)
But it's more than enough. Based on the trailer I'm fairly confident
I cannot only tell you the narrative arc of these episodes, but also what the deeper meaning of it all is
You see, it's my theory to that this new season is gonna be about the current
political situation in America, and
The duck is Donald Trump. And if that's sounds crazy (DONALD IS HIDING EVERYONE RUN!!!)
remember that this is a show where a boy wanders off from a picnic
and almost ends up in a cult that worships a God who eats gravel
So it's time to pick apart the trailer and see just
how deep this Rabbit hole goes. To put
"Wakey Wakey" into as much context as i can, let's
do a quick recap of the originals six episodes and my theory for what
was really going on. Don't Hug Me I'm Scared
follows three main characters. The red guy, the yellow guy and the
duck on a children's TV program that the red guy created and
that all of them star in. The show is being corrupted by the
show's producer, financier
yellow guy's creepy stage dad, Roy
"My dad is a com-com-computer"
Who's goal seems to be sell products and torture his son
both of which seem to be the main messages of DHMIS as a
whole. The harmful effects that money and
advertising can have on art
and the corruption of children's programming by that kind of
for profit agenda. after
Red guy discovers that their show can be made cheaply and distributed onto computers
his head literally explodes as he sees a way
foward without the influence of Roy the Duck
similary gets tired of and consumed by the show the latter again
quite literaly before the red guy discovers the harmful
effects that it's having on kids Yellow guy included. He
pulls the plug on the show and the final scene of the final episode reveals
that they're moving forward with a lower budget independent reboot
of the first ever episode, so that's where we're coming from
now cut to "Wakey Wakey"
where we get an establishing shot of "Clayhill" the town where it seems
these characters live outside of the context of the show
we get a quick shot of Red Guy walking through the Forrest followed by
what looks like a classic episode of their usual show with the key
as a teacher
We get a couple of shots of computer machinery with the Ducks face on it
Then, see a snapshot of a dark room in a state of disarray
and the Ducks face on a large screen behind the now locked gates
of Clayhill. Then, we have got ourselves a psychedelic
door and a shot of a purple marble. I don't know.
A lot of people online think this looks like South Parks
member berries
It would be a weird reference for them to make. Anyway,Wakey Wakey ends simple with Don't Hug Me I'm Scared.
And then the production companies. Blink industries, Conaco, and Super Deluxe.
It's not a ton to go off of, but if you actually slow it down,
Pay attention to the details, and think about who's actually making this show.
Some really solid narrative possibilities start to develop.
First and Foremost, it's important to note that the room
That is partially destroyed in the trailer is,
On closer inspection, the office of Clayhill's Mayor.
As we can see by the picture of him on the wall
And the identifying medal in the picture, on his desk. (Also the name plate on the desk)
Something happened to the mayor of this town.
Notice also it's discovered by the duck.
See this shot of him opening the doors, and this duck-billed shadow
When we're actually presented with the room.
This is going to be important later on. The disappearance or even murder
of gen Z most of you guys watching
who are known to be the most accepting generation inclusive,
diverse, and eager to change the world to make it a more
tolerate place and that is the WAKEY WAKEY
that the trailers referencing a wake up for America
and a reference to  the woke generation
the ultimate question is will Yellow guy be able to do it
we'll just have to wait and see
but hey that 's Just A Theory
A Film Theory! And
The lesson of today is subscribing. (NO,NO,NOOOO!!)
Subscribing is a good
idea If you want
to see the videos when they
come out. Subscribe (That'd just childish matpat... Subtitles made by dalva phillips P.s don't let matpat get ya!)